um i'm commonly kachowski from uc san
diego and this is joint work with my
student
uh chi chandra so
classification it's uh you know it's one
of the basic problems
figure out
okay excellent excellent okay so this is
you know so there are some people who
are not machine learners in the audience
for them anything this is
like a basic problem that we machine
learn as well right
classification we are given a bunch of
vectors of features
uh you know these are a bunch of
examples they have some discrete labels
in this case
you know we'll be mostly looking at
binary labels in the stock so like think
about them as plus or minus red or black
or whatever
and what we want to do is we want to
find a prediction rule in a class
that will predict these discrete labels
based on these examples
so just to give you a concrete example
in this figure what's going on
is we want here we want a linear
classifier right so we
have this line so these are these points
into 2d
we have this line on one side of the
line uh
we have the reds large you know and on
the other side we have large data blacks
so what this uh so this line gives you a
rule
that can predict whether this example
would be labeled red or black
right and you know this is it may not be
perfectly perfectly correct but it's
largely correct
okay uh however
the problem with building such
classifiers is the following right so
you may want to build such classifiers
which are really really complex
involve a lot of features of the
examples uh the problem with
it is you need a lot of data to build
these classifiers
and while unlabeled data is plentiful
you know you can easily access a lot of
unlabeled data
labeling data is expensive right so you
know somebody has to sit down and write
down the labels
and that's uh that's expensive and so
what we would look at is you know so
something we'll look at in this talk is
active learning which is one of the ways
of getting around it
and here instead of giving the y i so
remember we were given x i y i pairs
what we are given is some way to make
interactive label queries so we are
looking at algorithms where
you get a few x i y i's and then based
on these label data you say okay give me
and you get a lot of excise but based on
this label data you can say okay give me
the labels to this one that one and the
other
right and you know based on these labels
you can you know you
calculate a class you compute a
classifier and you can have multiple
rounds of feedback also right so you can
based on these labels you can ask for
some more some more and so on
right and your goal is to find the
prediction rule
to predict y's from x using as few of
these label queries as possible
so the difference is instead of all the
y is all together you have unlabeled
data
and the power of interaction and on
these unlabeled data points
and what you want to do is find a
prediction rule to predict the y's from
x's
using few label queries so why would you
expect active learning to help
so let's look at a little toy example
for this so let's say you start with
this unlabeled data
you ask for that label you get the red
point and then you ask for this one you
get a black
you know your boundary is somewhere
between this red and black
you ask for that other label okay it's a
red
maybe ask about this one in the center
and now you know there's only if you're
trying to fit a linear classifier you
know that
there's only one linear classifier which
will agree with all these things right
and what happened over here is because
you use active learning
instead of you know instead of looking
at all these labels
you only had to look at this four okay
and this is the case where active
learning actually helped
uh however there is a catch right so the
talk doesn't end here there is a catch
and the catch is
the challenging case for active learning
is uh
agnostic active learning so what is
agnostic learning
uh in the so here we come back to the
realm of learning theory
uh in learning theory there are you know
two basic models that people look at you
know i'm simplifying things a lot but
these are the two basic models um in the
pac model what happens
is you're given a c you're what happens
is you're given a concept class so think
about
a concept class could be for example the
class of all linear classifiers
a whole bunch of samples from a data
distribution
and your goal is to find a concept in
this class with low error
right so this is your basic goal and now
there are two
two different settings that people look
at one the first setting is realizable
where there exists a perfect classifier
in your class right
and the second one is agnostic where
there doesn't actually exist a perfect
classifier so for example over here you
know the contrast is
uh if you look at these two pictures
over here there is a little blob of gray
right there's a little blob of minus
among the pluses right
and you know whatever linear classifier
you choose you can never
separate the pluses and minuses
perfectly right so this is the agnostic
setting
okay and and basically your active you
know
agnostic active learning is essentially
doing active learning the problem we
talked about
in the agnostic setting now you have you
know
now your goal is to find a concept in c
whose error
is uh plus epsilon you know whose error
is at most plus
epsilon of the optimal right so now you
have uh you know your you have some
classifier
which is the best classifier in your
class and you want to get something
which has error close to it
uh using few label queries and with no
assumptions on the data distribution
so you're still allowed to make
interactive label queries you're given a
bunch of excise drawn from d
but now what happens is you want to get
close to the
best classifier in your class and you
can
and you have really no assumptions on
your data distribution
and why is agnostic active learning hard
if you look at this you know toy example
we looked at earlier
in this uh earlier in this talk we found
that we had four labels and we could
find this classifier
now if this was the agnostic case this
is what could have happened
right maybe these were the true labels
and what we found over there was simply
a local minimum
and if you had all the labels you would
have realized that
actually the true classifier is you know
the best classifier in that class is
that one
right and because you were so confident
you know you saw this red and you
thought okay here is the decision
boundary
you drill down into it and and if you
use a
drill down into it so you ended up in
the local minimum
and even if you had an infinite label
budget
because you used this very uh extra
confidence strategy
uh your algorithm would be statistically
inconsistent
right you would always find the local
minimum so the main challenge
is in agnostic active learning okay so
there are two existing solutions for
agnostic active learning
i'm going to go over them like really
really quickly uh the first one is
called disagreement-based active
learning
you know we'll come back to this a
little later it's a very general
solution um
and but it's a very conservative it's a
very general solution in the sense that
it will work for it's just a general
strategy
it will work for any concept class any
data distribution
but the problem is that it has a high
level requirement okay
the second line of work is called margin
based active learning
uh this gives such a geometric algorithm
and it applies for linear classification
with respect to
when your unlabeled data distribution is
the uniform or log-concave distribution
on the sphere
uh here the idea is that this is you
know it gives you
a lower label requirement you need less
labels than you would for
disagreement-based active learning
but the con is that it's not very
general it only applies in this very
specific case
okay and now the main question is
whether there's a general algorithm
which can give you better legal
complexity
than disagreement with active learning
and that's the question that we will be
looking at
in this talk okay and that's where we
come to confidence-based active learning
uh before i go into active learning
algorithms let me start off with one
concept
right so the concept that we'll be
looking at is that of a confidence rated
predictor i'm going to call it crp it's
not
a chinese restaurant process so a
confidence rated predictor
is a classifier that can abstain so you
have a classifier
which can you know which can if it
wanted to it can say i don't know
right it doesn't actually have to answer
okay and
how would you measure the performance of
such classifiers well you know the usual
metric is error which is the
rate of mistakes however you can always
say don't know and you know your error
would be zero
so what you need is an additional metric
which is the abstention rate
which is essentially the rate at which
you say i don't know right so you want
something which has low error
and low abstention rate okay that that's
that's the best confidence rate of
predictor
uh what we would be looking at is a
specific kind of confidence rated
predictor which is called the confidence
rated predictive and guaranteed error
uh here you are given a concept set v
and error guarantee
some unlabeled data and your goal
uh is to assign you know you have this
unlabeled data
and you want to assign labels to this
data right and the labels could be
either plus one
minus one or zero which basically means
i don't know and the guarantee that you
want to enforce
is that for all concepts in v
the probability so when you do predict a
label the probability that you predict
the wrong label
is at most data right so what what are
you doing intuitively what you are doing
is you are saying okay
um i don't know which you know i know
that my
best hypothesis uh best best concept is
a concept in v
i don't know which one so i will be
conservative and i will make sure
that i do not disagree with any of the
concepts in v
by more than eta so intuitively that is
that is what is going on over here right
that is what is confidence rate of
predictor is doing
okay and our work is based on two key
ideas
the first is a reduction from active
learning to a confidence rated predictor
which has this kind of properties
and then i will show you how to
construct such a confidence rate of
predictor
okay so uh first let's look at the
reduction
you know here is the problem you have
unlabeled data concept class
you're also given a confidence rate
predictor and you have a target excess
error
and you uh and you want to output a good
classifier right with few label queries
the problem is which labels to query
okay
so uh before i go into which labels to
query let me introduce one more concept
uh which is the concept of uh what
confidence set for c star right so
recall c star is the
concept in c which has the best error
right
and what we will be doing is we will be
looking at our confidence set for c star
so what is a confidence set well it's a
subset of concepts in c
such that with probability greater than
equal to 1 minus delta
c star is in this subset right and you
know the idea is exactly like confidence
intervals
uh instead you know but instead of like
little numbers now we have these uh
classifiers so it's a set right it's a
set of objects instead of being an
interval
okay so that's it's the same idea and
what we would
so how do we construct these confidence
sets uh i won't go into any details
right now
but it turns out that you know learning
theorists have
a lot of you know built up these things
called generalization bounds and this is
like a very very basic one
uh and what you can do is you can uh use
these generalization bounds to construct
confidence sets
for c star okay okay so back to the
active learning algorithm
uh what we will be doing is we will be
going in epochs
right uh at each epoch our target error
would be something like let's say one
over two to the k at the kt park and the
problem we are back to is how to query
the labels
okay so uh
now here comes uh so what we will do is
we have you know two key ideas
in this paper and here comes the first
one right
how do we query the labels well we are
going to run
our confidence rated predictor p that we
were given
with an error guarantee so remember it
had you know this confidence rated
predictor had a parameter which was
there
a guarantee the error guarantee would be
epsilon k was 64
where epsilon k is the target error in
this epoch
and when this confidence predictor says
i don't know
we are going to query the label okay so
essentially you have you're at this
epoch you have a certain target error in
this epoch
you run your confidence rate of
predictor with an error guarantee
you know which is some constant times
this target
when this confidence predictor says i
don't know that is when you query the
labels
okay so this is uh this is the first
question
now the next question is how many labels
are we going to query
because um you know so because we have
to
so it turns out because you know we have
to get to targeted or epsilon k right so
the question is how many tables do we
query
uh and our key idea is we need to query
in this epoch
just enough labels to get target excess
error
epsilon k plus one over phi k in the
don't know region
right where phi k is uh p's abstention
probability
so there is a donor region so we are
acquiring labels for examples in the
donor region
but we need to query just enough labels
to get target excess error epsilon k
plus 1
over vk okay so if we needed to query
enough labels to get targeted or epsilon
k
just epsilon k plus one that would have
been passive learning
right now epsilon k plus one over phi k
is actually you know fifa is always less
than one right less than equal to one
so this is actually a larger quantity
right and that's where we save
okay so that's that's where the saving
comes from
okay and so that that's uh that's that's
uh something to observe
and finally observe that if p is
actually a good confidence writer
predicted in the sense that
with the same error guarantee if it says
don't know less often
then we would actually need less labels
so again to recap this is the algorithm
you run your confidence rated predictor
with the unlabeled data you were given
be equal to this
confidence set that we obtained
and error guarantee eta is epsilon k
over 64.
whenever p apps tends we query enough
labels to get excess error epsilon uh
sorry the association k
plus 1 over vk in the donor region and
then
uh we already had a confidence set uh we
started with a confidence set for
you know for c star now we have seen
some new labels
we update this confidence set based on
the new label samples that we have seen
okay and you keep doing it for log one
over epsilon rounds
at the end you output a concept in any
concept
in v log one over epsilon okay
okay now let's look at how to construct
such a confidence rated predictor
remember this is a definition um you
wanted to
you would like to assign a label such
that this error guarantee is satisfied
okay and here is the construction uh
we use a linear program for every
unlabeled data point
we have two variables so we'll have a
soft predictor for every valuable data
points we have two variables alpha
and beta i alpha is the probability of
predicting plus one on this uh unlabeled
point
beta is the probability of predicting
minus one right and then you know one
minus alpha minus beta i is
uh the probability of abstaining okay
and so what you do is you maximize
the non-abstention rate subject to
this constraint uh which can which is
essentially the error guarantee right so
this constraint says that for all
concepts in v um the fraction of points
on which i
you know on on which this predictor says
minus but
uh c says plus plus the
fraction of concepts on which uh this
predictor says plus
but c says minus is at most eta right
data times the size of the unlabeled
data
and this is the error guarantee and then
you know
we have a probability constraint and and
that's basically it
okay and then the thing to observe and
then that's basically it and once you
solve this lp
what you get is uh you know these alphas
and beta
eyes what you should do is for each zi
you should probably you should output
one with probability alpha
minus 1 with probability beta i and 0
with probability 1 minus alpha minus
beta i
right and the thing to note also by the
property
of the you know the baby set of this lp
uh this lp will give you this this
confidence rated predictor will give you
the optimal abstention rate
given the concept set v okay if you want
to
you know if you want a confidence
represented error which has exactly
these inputs this is the best that you
can do
so this was uh essentially our algorithm
outline
okay so now we uh come to performance
guarantees what can we say about the
algorithm
uh first let's look at consistency
because that's that's what we started
from
okay it turns out that if your p
is a confidence rated predictor with
guaranteed error
then you know this reduction is
consistent then the active learning
algorithm you get out of it
is going to be consistent it's going to
always converge to a global optimum
local optimum it wouldn't have this
problem that we saw in the example
uh it turns out in fact that
disagreement based active learning
actually also falls in this framework so
there is a specific confidence rated
predictor due to elian evan weiner
so if you plug this confidence rated
predictor into this active learning
framework
what you would get back is essentially a
form of disagreement this activity
okay so what about its label complexity
uh
so this is uh you know one slide which
is going to be a little dense
uh remember our parameters are the
target error epsilon
we say dimension d of the concept class
so for the purpose of this talk you know
think about d as being some measure of
complexity of this complex
of this concept class what measure it
doesn't particularly matter
and the error of the best concept in c
is a new star
right so these are our parameters for
disagreement based active learning
uh this is the bound that you're going
to get for agnostic case okay so let me
explain this
term by term the term that i have
highlighted in yellow
this is what is called the disagreement
coefficient and it measures the rate of
change of the disagreement region
right so this is like a derivative of
some sort if you will
very intuitively like loosely speaking
after disagreement region
um at this point okay and
this is the disagreement coefficient and
then you have terms like this right so
this term
is kind of the dominant term and this is
d
times nu star squared times log one over
epsilon over epsilon squared
okay so this is a kind of the dominant
term this times the disagreement
coefficient
if you look at our algorithm we can also
get a very similar bound
however the disagreement coefficient has
now been replaced
by this new term sigma right so this is
a sigma
of 2 nu star plus epsilon comma
let's say epsilon over 256 the constants
are not too important
okay and this term is the way to think
about this term
is it's uh it's a term like the
disagreement coefficient
it is the rate of change of the donor
region
of ah of an optimal confidence rated
predictor with guaranteed error
defined in a certain way so i don't want
to go into the formal definition here
so this is uh kind of you know this this
so you should con
compare this term with the disagreement
coefficient right
and it turns out that this term is
actually lower than this disagreement
lower than or equal to the disagreement
coefficient okay
and so basically our algorithm
so what you conclude at the end of this
is essentially
if you do the label complexity analysis
instead of the disagreement
coefficient you have something else
which is a better term
okay and just as a very simple baseline
uh let's look at passive learning so for
passive learning what happens is you get
uh d nu star times log one over epsilon
over epsilon squared right and the
difference here
is uh here you have a new star square
right so new star is always less than
one
so this is a slightly better um
so that that's that's the that's
essentially the difference okay
uh and uh so now um
just to give you um an idea about where
active learning helps
if you try to look at these bounds
closely uh what would happen
is until you get to a constant times new
star
active learning would help once you get
close to new start then it doesn't help
so much
okay so that's that's the idea
and remember i uh mentioned margin-based
active learning
it turns out that um our algorithm
also uh captures some form of
margin-based active learning
so if you look at the bounds that we get
in those specific cases log concave
distribution or uniform distribution on
the sphere
then the bounds that we get match the
bounds of margin based active learning
uh and you know so this is what the
bound looks like uh so here
what we get out of our algorithm and
also imagine best active learning
is the dominant term is d log one over
epsilon so this is a realizable case in
diagnostic case there's also something
uh similar
and with this agreement based active
learning what you would have gotten
is d to the three half log squared one
over epsilon so that would have been the
dominant term
and our algorithm is uh doing better
okay so you can think about it as a
generalization of margin based active
learning
so in conclusion we have uh you know we
give a
new reduction from active learning to
confidence with the predictor
with uh you know with guaranteed error
and
which exploits essentially the non-zero
error guarantee so you know previously
uh you know this kind of reduction was
um you know you could have easily so the
reduction between um if you had a
confidence rated predictor that had a
zero error guarantee
then this is quite easy right and you
know but
the tricky part is to exploit this
non-zero error guarantee to get a better
labor requirement so that is the new
tricky part of you know this is a new
part and this is the tricky part
and we use this reduction to give a
novel active learning algorithm
which has better asymptotic and
obviously these things are all
asymptotic
uh i don't have the exact constants
label complexity then disagreement based
and it's more general than margin base
okay and
our algorithm is not quite you know
practical or computationally efficient
the open question is how to make it
practical
thank you
one or two quick questions yes um
so uh sasha rockman and i had a paper in
nibs 2011 world of
information theoretic lower bounds for
active learning and they're controlled
by something called alexander capacity
the supremum of that yes so how does
your
achievability result here compared to
alexander
right so uh if i remember correctly you
guys had the alexander capacity was in
the logarithmic term
yes right and so here the the constant
term is uh different
that's that's that because we so we
actually captured the separation between
you know
uh active and passive in terms of
relative scaling
right and there was a margin term also
right so we explained this in our paper
but
uh you know not in this talk yeah the
labels assumed to be noiseless
uh no they're not okay so the labels
could be whatever they are
you're just trying to in diagnostic
setting you're just trying to capture
um you know you're just trying to find
the best classifier in the class